because they're made for men without
legs well I mean which as you can
clearly see is not a problem Wow
you know if if I liked it I should have
put a ring on it I suppose yeah who says
I'm not wearing a second so here we are
on the Sunday special with steven
crowder laxed pants and we will get to
all of the questions for steven crowder
we will ask him why indeed he feels that
it is necessary and appropriate for him
not to wear pants and thus to show his
junk to the entire world
look steven crowder could use a
therapist and you might need to as well
all you need is a computer but I'm so
tempted to screw all of them up for you
I know and you already had one so
congratulations you did you did you did
stumble a little bit I know well you
know you actually ducking into my camera
line and then pouring water into your
own mug is always definitely a wonderful
no I just don't trust you look back at
you dude I mean I'm the one wearing
pants so all I can say is that when
before it began this interview steven
crowder was in fact wearing pants
you walk into the room not wearing pants
to make me specifically uncomfortable
because as most people know I am deeply
uncomfortable with the male body but why
are you such xx such an angry Jew today
God dang in who booked this why am I
even here Oh God not prouder than he's
long enough do you think Bernie Sanders
would care more if you gave him $10,000
or if you dedicated your entire network
to kissing his ass for an election cycle
[Music]
let's talk a little bit about how you
got to where you are so he runs a show
boy I mean I'm happy and he'll respect
always I'm Jewish but you know Ed
Crowder is sitting here and and I will
tell you what when he turned on I think
we had a guest who came in or I was
playing with my nipples no wait that was
where I have a I have a hole in my
sternum here and no one believed me so
we tried to see I have a inverted
sternum so I was trying to see how many
coffee beans we could fit in my sternum
take a guess
[Music]
208 coffee beans consider my sternum
maybe we are all dead in this that was a
self patch for sponsors don't see how
creative you can complement those it's
okay yeah no it means you're smart it's
smooth I tell you what's not smart as
these generic chairs my back's gonna be
so I might take it up and stretch right
in front of you well please do not and
and in any case so I think even though
this thing is squeaking it's being
caught up on here is it all right fine
I'm just making sure this I'm it's the
replication it's not made for me Shawn
you okay no no I'm making sure that
people know it's not me is my point then
this is important for me it's not
everything is about you there you go you
can hear this week it's the checkout
prevent thank you be on the show sir hey
thanks for thanks for having me as
always I mean it's always wonderful to
see you and watch you dance and just
think to myself what have I done with my
life
you can speak ill of anything that the
hell are you doing on your iPad ma'am
well I mean I'm decrypting all sorts of
national security secret okay now or no
certainly not certainly not doing no
you're watching interdimensional vampire
that's correct in any case let's talk
about the fact you're crazy person I
don't know what you have I don't know
what it is a computer wore tennis shoe
syndrome I have no idea comes big do too
I imagine he actually has to Crisco
himself up just wedge himself doorways
to get around that at that point the
crisco's incidental it's not to wedge
himself from the doorway there's a
multitude of uses get back in there
make some shoes and a ben shapiro
tumbler don't come out until you've paid
if they weren't making shoes that our
family would starve as usual
legend that is why I shuffle II at the
gap so uh Ben first let's talk about
changed is this studio right here
doesn't have any pants but he could use
some pants because come the hell on it's
just terrible in every possible way it's
very hard for me to get jeans because I
have a pretty small waist but a huge ass
so I was gonna mention it now there's a
their pants my waist is 33 left about 36
to 38 pants because they're made for men
without legs well I mean which as you
can clearly see is not a problem
Wow yeah if I like it I should put a
ring on it I suppose yeah who says I'm
not wearing a second ring no that's
continue with your question on my
worldview good Family Values oh wow wow
so thanks much for stopping by dude it's
great to see you thank you sir animal
later if you like this video I would say
subscribe hit the notification bell or
watch one of these videos playing in a
box that we've personally uploaded in
program for your viewing pleasure the
problem is now in today's day and age on
YouTube in 2018 any of those three
things that you do any of those three
buttons that you click will take you
directly to a Seth Meyers video so stay
here and join my get off of here go to
lateral credit I come /mo Club it's the
only safe place you can go enjoy